welcome back
these are the days where i literally
come into work pinching myself thinking
that i am in the dream job of all dream
jobs because our next guest well there's
just nothing that he can't do he's an
actor an author a 16-time winning wwe
world champion
he's adding superhero to his resume of
esteemed acting i think he's an
incredible comedian as well
and his new hbo mac show the peacemaker
is about to drop take a look
why are you in your costume
costume this is a uniform and it's brand
new so i'm gonna stretch it out make it
more comfortable before going to mission
maybe i'm stupid but why would you even
want to wear that on a mission a bright
red shirt and white pants aren't exactly
conducive to lurking in the shadows
people see this uniform and strikes fear
in their hearts what people the other
people at the village people try out
please welcome everybody's favorite the
very talented john cena
[Applause]
thank you so much for having me
thank you guys
thank you
we sit can we talk do you sit and talk i
would love to sit and talk um
thank you for everything that you do
i always thought when i was a kid i
looked at other people in the same
job force that i was in and i always
admired the ones where i'm like i don't
know if they're
dramatic i don't know
if they're a comedian i don't know
if they're this or they're that like
every person that i admire most taught
me
to have range
and that range was one of the greatest
art forms that we could have because you
never really knew where someone was
coming from which was not only exciting
but meant that they could diversify
their portfolio
and that is utility
it's true
thank you very much she's way way too
kind so uh
thank you
um
that is uh that's that's very nice of
you to say i'm i'm uh
still very much in the learning process
of all this but uh a lot of the comedy
especially with me being a big lumbering
individual is not taking myself too
seriously and being able to laugh at
myself coming on a television show
dressed as peacemaker is my my stylist
has
she fired me
and and she's my wife so uh
trouble at the workplace but anyway um
here i am dressed as a superhero and uh
we got a show out on hbo max and
to say i'm not nervous is a boldface lie
i'm so excited because i'm nervous at
work all the time yeah but that's okay i
think
i think if you get to that point
where you're not nervous you talk to any
athlete who takes the field before game
if they get to that point where they
lose that edge
even as a live performer man i've gone
down that ramp
way too many times
but every single time there's that
moment right before you pull the curtain
back
you just it's a it's a feeling an
indescribable feeling of
everything at peak insanity and then you
go out
and it's amazing
even when it's
the the long nights where you suck it's
amazing um but there's not a night
there's not a time there's not a time
that i've ever walked around that door
that i'm not nervous
i don't think you i i do think you know
how valuable
that is that's helping me right now
because i'm scared in this job all the
time i am i i
i try to be a journalist i've never been
a talk show host before
i'm dealing with broadcast in a digital
age there is everything that i'm trying
to figure out
on the job sometimes and that just made
me feel less alone i think you're doing
great as a talk show host i think you're
doing great as a journalist
that means so much to me coming from you
you're such a good person
now i love the fact that you have had
many jobs including
being a groundskeeper to golf course
and an ice cream
like scooper but one of my favorites is
that you were a limo driver i was so i
was about uh 19 this was pre-gps you
still had to buy a map i grew up in the
small town of west newbury massachusetts
1 500 people strong and it is one hour
and uh 30 minutes north of boston i'd
never been to the city in my entire life
i was given a job driving lincoln town
cars to and from logan airport a place
i'd never been to in my life
i also was 225 pounds by the time i was
19 years old and i was uh training for a
bodybuilding competition at the time so
i brought my food in the car
uh my lincoln town car smelled of
steamed chicken breast and tuna fish
so um i was always late and i mean late
i would pick people up
two and a half hours late for their
flight
yeah
uh i earned every single expletive that
i was called
and i got i got to handle the passengers
they came up with some new stuff i'd
never even heard and i grew up with four
brothers all right so i love that i read
that you like doing interviews because
you think it gives you a chance to like
let people in on you is this true well
uh there's there's a lot of reasons i
like doing interviews first of all it's
part of the process yes and uh we also
have to get people interested you can
have the best performance in the world
if nobody knows about it nobody's gonna
go see it and you can't do it again and
you're making what's called a home video
like
great i want people to come see and and
a lot of that is is spreading the word
letting people know peacemakers on hbo
max so you guys go and see it so i can
be peacemaker again uh and and that this
is this is part of that thank you very
much you guys are going to love it it's
so
good i am
loving it so much
and we're actually going to get into if
you don't mind i'd like to try and do
some peacekeeping keep peace
you know what let's do it right now okay
cool all right so we have a mom and a
daughter eliana and annanziata and uh we
were wondering what your conflict is and
john and i are going to attempt he's
going to take the lead and again i am
totally not qualified
this is just my personal opinion with no
backing whatsoever but i'm gonna do my
best i would love to ask what is your
conflict
so our little conflict um my mom and i
are super close we've been like really
close ever since i was little
um and i'm 19 so i'm in college now i go
to school in missouri but the issue here
is that my mom
she's very italian and she loves being
part of every little aspect of my life
and knowing all the details
but as a adult now um i want some more
privacy especially like in my dating
life and things like that how do we
navigate
that kind of situation yeah i i heard um
i heard your opinion anything to add
over there
and then theater do you have something
to say i just worry about anything and
everything i don't i don't know what's
out there i i i just worry about
anything and everything so
um i just want to you know make sure
she's good and she's safe and kind of
want to know what her daily life is like
but first of all in no way shape or form
am i a parent but i am a child
and
i found my best connection with my
parents
is
transferring that
parent-child relationship into a
peer-adult relationship
and
maybe it's time for you as a daughter to
begin approaching conversation to your
mom uh
about adult subjects or just the the
yearning to wanting to be
treated as an adult not a child and
maybe it's time for you as a mom
uh to think about you know as as your
daughter gets older more educated wiser
to the ways of the world uh how you want
to go about redefining your relationship
so you don't look at her as a child an
incapable child when she's desiring
freedom and maybe you both evolve in a
way where you can grow as mother and
daughter together
but
as two adults your adult relationship
with your daughter is going to be a
whole lot longer than the childhood one
right and and for me personally this
didn't happen at 19.
like uh that's when
i i was very rebellious to my parents at
that point because i really thought they
were um they were just trying to protect
me but i thought they were they were
trying to hold me back so when i say
i've developed a strong relationship
this is this is just fairly recently
last decade or so so maybe just
start planting the seeds now for that
foundation of
uh your future relationship where your
your two adults
who can who can uh share the magic of
adult life
okay um is there another show that you
and i are supposed to be in together
where we fully do like relationships
human interests like
i'm having a blast
okay well let
let's go to commercial and then just get
right back into this conversation if you
don't mind we'll be right back
[Applause]
[Music]